hi this is press talker in this video
I'm going to present three different
puzzles that involve matches in the
first puzzle
we'll take eight matches to create a
stick-figure fish which has its head
facing to the left the puzzle is can you
move only three of the matches so that
the fish swims to the right in other
words you want the same shape at the end
but you want the head to be looking to
the right side the second puzzle will
use four matches to create a cup and
inside of the cup we have ice cubes the
puzzle is you have to move only two of
the matches and you still end up with
the same shape of the cup but once you
have the solution the ice will be on the
outside of the cup
in the third puzzle we're going to take
matches and form a mathematical equation
five plus seven equals two now this is
obviously an incorrect equation the
puzzle is can you move only one match to
fix the equation so it's mathematically
correct
give the puzzles a try I've linked to
the solution in the video description or
you can click through please subscribe
to my channel you can support me on
patreon catch me on my blog mine your
decisions on Twitter at pressure Locker
and you can get my books listed on my
website